two baseball teams are comparing the
number of fans who attended their most
recent games
the attendance at the stanleyville
sliders game was 12 896 fans the
attendance at the benson bats game was
12 901 fans
which team had more fans at their game
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out
alright let's work through this together
now stanleyville sliders they tell us
stanleyville sliders game was twelve
thousand
twelve thousand
eight hundred and ninety six and there's
a reason why i'm writing it really large
right over there
and then we see at the benson bats the
benson the benson bats game was twelve
thousand nine hundred one
twelve thousand
nine hundred
and one
so the way i like to compare numbers is
i go to the the largest place value
first and i compare well let's see they
both have one ten thousand
so they have the same number of ten
thousands they have the same number of
thousands
but then when we get to hundreds notice
benson bats has more hundreds than
stanleyville sliders it doesn't matter
what happens in the tens and ones place
if they have more hundreds over here so
benson bats this is a larger number so
which one has more fans of their game
benson's bats and once again i start the
largest place value started the ten
thousands place it was the same then i
move on to the next place it's the same
then i move on to the next place but now
in the hundreds place benson's bats is
larger so i know that benson's bats is
going to be has more fans than
stanleyville sliders i could write this
as 12
901 is greater than
and i always remember the sign by saying
hey it opens to the larger value so this
is going to be greater than
12 000
eight hundred and ninety six and you can
even just think about it just keep
counting twelve hundred thousand eight
hundred ninety six twelve thousand eight
hundred ninety seven twelve thousand
eight hundred ninety eight twelve
thousand eight hundred ninety nine
twelve thousand nine hundred and then
twelve thousand nine hundred 901
all right let's do another example
the table shows the weights of several
animals at the zoo
put the animals in order from lightest
to heaviest the lightest animal should
be on the top of the list and so you
could see it right over here they give
us
these three animals
and if you're doing this on khan academy
you'd be able to click on these and move
them around but i'm just i just copy and
pasted the actual image so let's just
think about these weights so let's look
at the let's first let's do the same
thing let's first look and actually
pause the video and try to solve it on
your on your own
all right so if we first look at the
thousands place remember we started the
the largest place value so the thousands
place they all have exactly two
thousands so now we move on to the
hundreds place
so both the polar bear and the crocodile
has has two hundreds but the giraffe
only has one hundred so the giraffe is
the lightest and remember we're ordering
from lightest heaviest because this has
the least number of hundreds they all
have the same number of thousands and so
then we move to one space to the right
to the hundreds and the giraffe has the
least number of hundreds
so the giraffe
the giraffe is going to be the lightest
and so now let's think about between the
polar bear and the crocodile
they both have the same number of
thousands they have the same number of
hundreds they have the same number of
tens
but notice the polar bear has more ones
than the crocodile and so the cro then
so the polar bear is heavier so the
crocodile comes next it's the next
heaviest or the next lightest
crocodile and then the heaviest is
the polar bear
the polar bear and once again you start
at the largest place value you compare
they were the same then you go the next
largest oh there's a difference so this
one must be lighter doesn't matter what
happens in the tens and ones because it
has fewer hundreds than these right over
here and so if you were sorting these
around you would want to
put the giraffe first and then you would
then you would put the crocodile and
then the polar bear would stay last so
actually you would just swap you would
just swap these two right over here
let's do one more this is a lot of fun
all right
let me
scroll down a little bit
pause this video now and see if you can
solve this
the table shows the elevations for three
mountains in north america
abby is trying to guess the elevation of
university peak she knows that it is
taller than mount massive but not as
tall as mount oliver stone so it is
between mount oliver stone and mount
massive so it is right over here taller
than mount massive but not as tall as
mount alverstone
all right fill in the blank with an
elevation abby could guess for the
elevation of university peak enter a
whole number solution
so we have to think of a number that is
larger than 14428
and smaller than 14
400.
well
one possibility is we'll just add one to
mount massive so one possibility is
fourteen thousand
four hundred and twenty nine that would
be taller than mount massive but not as
tall as mount oliver stone it still has
fewer this still has even though it has
more ones than mount massive everything
else is the same it has fewer hundreds
than mount oliver stone so that could be
we could write 14
429 we could have also written 14
430 and we could have kept going all the
way until 14
499.
they all they want us to enter whole
number solutions so any of these would
have been acceptable answers